und bei uns jetzt paul ronzheimer
zugeschaltet aus kiew der hauptstadt
dort wo sich die schlinge immer weiter
zu zieht was befürchten die menschen
dort für die kommenden stunden für die
kommenden tage jeden tag bereits der
vergangenen tage fragte man sich ist es
jetzt soweit ist es jetzt soweit und
diese frage steht weiterhin im raum
patricia sie steht nicht nur im raum es
ist völlig klar das ist so kommen wird
aus meiner sicht zumindest sei denn es
passiert ein wunder ein wunder für kiew
das wäre diese menschen diesen
wunderbaren menschen die in dieser
hauptstadt leben zu wünschen aber es
sieht nicht danach aus auch vor 15
minuten wieder sirenenalarm hier in der
stadt sehr sehr viel häufiger als in den
vergangenen tagen in der nacht mehrfach
gab es explosionen alle zwei stunden
fast hier einen alarm das ist weitaus
mehr als in der nacht zuvor
gleichzeitig auf den straßen erhöhte
nervosität wenn man dort durchfährt wie
wir gestern auch da wird mittlerweile an
jedem checkpoint alles kontrolliert
jeder kofferraum jedes dokument jeder
ausweis da wird kritisch nachgefragt wer
sind sie wirklich jeder ist ihr
verdächtig journalisten können
verdächtigt seien alle können
verdächtigt sein denn wir wissen das
längst russische scharfschützen hier in
der stadt sein soll partner soldaten
aber auch tschetschenische kämpfer und
das sind die die auf es auf low dose
lenski den ukrainischen präsidenten
abgesehen haben das hat er selbst gesagt
offenbar gab es bereits mehrere versuche
wenn ihn zu töten
diese anschläge konnten vereitelt werden
laut der ukrainischen regierung das ist
quellenlage ukrainische regierung
mehrere sind auf dieser liste auch
vitali klitschko den wir hier immer
wieder interviewen bei bild live der
sich hier um seine stadt kümmert vor
allem um die zivile versorgung darum
dass hier weiterhin dinge in die stadt
kommen können da geht es um
nahrungsmittel aber natürlich auch im
medizin putin zieht die schlinge um 4 zu
und nimmt dirigieren soll dort immer
mehr ins visier du hast selensky ukraine
präsident angesprochen der hat sich in
der nacht noch mal an sein volk gewandt
und auch ganz klar an putin soldaten
hören wir mal gemeinsam rein paul
müller hatte kießling machte anwohner
halb vor einer woche hat die ukraine die
pläne durchkreuzt pläne die seit
mehreren jahren plant wurden aus ras auf
die ukraine gegen unser volk gegen die
menschen die hier in freiheit leben
wollen gegen menschen die ein herz haben
aber wir haben sie aufgehalten und wir
werden sie vernichten unsere armee und
der grenzschutz wird durch zivilisten
verstärkt der moralische zustand der
armee verschlechtert sich und täglich
werden russische soldaten gefangen
genommen und sie sagen nur eine sache
sie wissen nicht wofür sie eigentlich
hier sind ukraine bekämpfen die russen
ohne waffen ich bin beeindruckt von den
heldentaten dieser menschen aus unserem
land sie lassen den besatzern nicht ins
land und sie versuchen den feind
aufzuhalten sie sperren die straßen mit
leib und leben dort war es am
gefährlichsten ist es zeigt wie mutig
diese menschen sind die russischen
soldaten sind keine krieger einer
supermacht das sind kinder die benutzt
wollen sind bringt sie nach hause die
ukraine will sich nicht mit gleichen
bedenken sagt euren befehlshaber dass
ihr leben holt und nicht sterben
und er schickt eine klare drohung an
putin soldaten sie werden hier in der
ukraine keine ruhige minute haben sagt
präsident selensky er hat sich in seinem
ton etwas verändert er ist jetzt
schärfer geworden er ist mehr ja im
krieg auch mit seinen worten angekommen
paul
ja absolut richtig keit das ist etwas
was ich auch wahrgenommen habe hier in
seiner ansprache wenn man ihn kennt den
ukrainischen präsidenten nicht wahr noch
vorjahr 12 13 tagen mit ihm zwei tage
unterwegs da wirkt er noch relativ
entspannt da hat er noch mal gelacht da
war immer noch eine lockerheit da ja
aber da war auch noch nicht der krieg
dort eigentlich ist es ein wunder dass
er bislang also bis zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt diese sprache noch nicht
verändert hatte diese martialische
sprache die automatisch kommt mit einem
krieg das kann man glaube ich gar nicht
verhindern wenn man sieht wie viele
menschen hier sterben wie viele
zivilisten sterben wie viele soldaten
und zwar weil wladimir putin für sich
den entschluss gefasst hat das aus
seiner sicht die ukraine nicht zu
russland gehört die die ukraine kann
eigener staat sondern zu russland gehört
und mit absurden begründung und ihren
theorien hier seine armee rhein
geschickt hat das nimmt natürlich den
präsidenten mit dieser psychoterror der
auf ihm lastet auf seiner familie laste
er hat kleine kinder und er muss das
ganze land zusammenhalten jedes wort von
ihm wird hier genau gehört jedes wort
von ihm kann aufschluss darüber geben in
welche richtung es geht im land und für
mich klingt es danach dass die ukraine
dass der ukrainische präsident in keiner
form einen plan hat möglicherweise hier
die waffen niederzulegen oder irgend
etwas in diese richtung zu tun wenn
putin das gehofft haben sollte sondern
dass die ukraine weiter kämpfen will und
das land verteidigen will und
gleichzeitig paul sehen wir hier die
bilder der zerstörung die du uns
mitgebracht hast wie geht es den
menschen in der ukraine es ist tag 8
dieses krieges jahren immer weiter aus
in kellern in bunkern und so sind bilder
aus kiew gestern sieht ihre stadt jetzt
aus
japan tritt hier tatsächlich ist es so
dass viele menschen im bunker aus haan
wir waren ja gestern sehr viel in der
stadt unterwegs waren dort am
fernsehturm haben die zerstörung gesehen
die dieser anschlag auch drumherum
ausgelöst hat komplett zerstörte gebäude
am frühen morgen lagen da noch die
leichen auf der straße also wirklich
dramatische eindrücke und dann sind wir
runter in den bunker der methode so ganz
tief rein geht und man sich eigentlich
theoretisch so gut es geht sicher fühlen
müsste aber selbst da haben wir die
menschen erzählt wir haben verschiedene
einschläge gehört hier haben die wände
gewackelt und auch selbst ihre haben der
angst und wenn man das sieht das der
menschen teilweise sieben tage bereits
also oder jetzt acht tage die gesamte
kriegszeit sich dort in den bunker
aufgehalten haben dann versteht man die
dramatik und die dramatische versteht
man noch mehr wenn man wie wir in einem
kinderkrankenhaus war gestern und dort
babys gesehen hat die geradezu welt sind
die ja in eine welt des krieges geboren
wurden ich war sehr bewegt von den
worten von meinem kameramann des motivs
der ist vor vier wochen vater geworden
einer tochter und als er dort die babys
gesehen hat hat er gesagt ich fühle mich
fast schlecht dass mein kind in einer
guten klinik in griechenland zur welt
gekommen ist wenn ich das hier sehe und
da sieht man wie diese beiden welten
nicht zueinander passen und natürlich
auch nicht zueinander passen sollten
weil die ukraine hat genauso frieden und
sicherheit verdient wie wir alle so ging
es auch gestern paul uns sind die bilder
nicht aus dem kopf gegangen und die
ganze zeit die frage mich wie kann man
all die kinder am liebsten herholen
zumindest für den moment mit ihren
müttern hier nach deutschland
gleichzeitig wissen es gibt im moment
gar kein ausweg aus der stadt kiew du
wirst sie viel gedanken machen in diesen
stunden wie das eigentlich weitergeht
mensch wir haben jetzt kriegstag 8 und
die bombardements die nehmen zu und wir
schauen auf diese bilder gewöhnen uns
fasst langsam daran und sehen überhaupt
kein ausweg putins armee wird nicht
geschlagen er wird nicht aufgeben was
ist im moment eine antwort wie das in
den nächsten tagen wochen weitergehen
könnte wohl möglicherweise ein ausweg
sein könnte
keiner ist wahrscheinlich die frage über
die ich am meisten nach denke in diesen
stunden in diesen tagen das ist die
frage über die ich am meisten spreche
mit allen politischen akteuren sei es
witali klitschko sei es bitter foto
schenk sei es die lenski berater und
keiner hat eine antwort das ist
eigentlich das was mich
was mir ein bisschen angst macht muss
ich sagen weil in konflikten und kriegen
die ich bislang
gecovert über die ich berichtet habe
natürlich gab es die ewigen kriege wie
zb in afghanistan oder in syrien auch
oder libyen all das aber wenn ich mir
anschaue wie es zum beispiel 2014 war
als die krim eingenommen wurde
annektiert wurde von russland und dann
in der ost ukraine etwas passierte man
wusste immer dass könnte der nächste
schritt sein und das wird wahrscheinlich
nicht tun das würde putin nicht tun das
war damals noch das gefühl dieses gefühl
ist vollkommen weg alle mit denen man
spricht glauben putin ist am ende zu
allem bereit was vielen sorge macht ist
wie oft er mittlerweile ich glaube drei
mal in der vergangenen woche über den
einsatz von atomwaffen gesprochen hat
und mit politikern mit denen ich spreche
ich werde jetzt nicht sagen wer aber mit
dem mann im hintergrund spricht als
journalist das bedeutet dass die dinge
nicht in der öffentlichkeit zitiert
werden die sagen mir sie können auch das
nicht mehr ausschließen dass taktische
atomwaffen zum einsatz kommen und da
fragt man sich wo sind wir angekommen in
nur acht tagen auf unserer welt wir
reden über einen möglichen einsatz von
taktischen atomwaffen ich hoffe und bete
dass es nicht soweit kommt und
unabhängig von diesen wirklich
ja nicht denkbaren optionen
wenn man über die ukraine nach denkt
auch da wo sind die wege was soll
passieren bei friedensgesprächen
wladimir putin sagt kain existiert nicht
wladimir putin sagt sie hat keine
existenz wladimir putin sagt hier wo ich
stehe in kirchner sind nur nazis wie
sollen diese beiden seiten zueinander
führt wird gleichzeitig wladimir putin
natürlich zu hause mit dem druck der
dort entsteht völlig zu recht mit den
sanktionen völlig zu recht
aber was soll seine option aus seiner
sicht wenn man versucht was natürlich
schon absurd ist aber sich in seinem
kopf rein zu versetzen wie kann er aus
dieser nummer rauskommen und da seien
auch alle hier in der ukraine er braucht
ein sieg um auch politisch zu überleben
und das bedeutet für mich am ende nur
eins er wird noch schärfere waffen
setzen noch mehr truppen rein schicken
und noch mehr leid anrichten